well let's talk about the woman who made
a Sin City history Celine Dion we know
that she's leaving the Colosseum at
Caesars Palace after sixteen triumphant
years but is it taking a toll on her
there's been some concern about Celine's
weight now she talked about that she
also talked about how it feels to turn
51 just three days ago I feel stronger
more beautiful more grounded Celine has
a new confidence and she had no problem
shutting down talk that she's too thin
GMA asked her this morning about health
concerns there are some who worried that
you're a little too thin what do you say
I'm thin I'm kind - you know it's true
that I'm a little thinner
everything's fine nothing's wrong I have
discovered a new passion dancing it's an
emotional time for Celine
after 1100 shows she's ending her reign
as the queen of Vegas residency her last
show is June 8th et was with her after
her first performance in 2003 tonight
was we did it and it felt great so
what's next well today we learned Selene
is working on a new album and planning a
tour more details are expected tomorrow
during a live streaming event and
there's this that's Selene and James
Corden recreating that iconic Titanic
scene sailing through the Bellagio
fountains the performance will air on a
Late Late Show primetime carpool karaoke
special May 20th Selene was also candid
today about life after her beloved
husband Renee who passed away over three
years ago you ready for love again at
some point I am in love you don't you
don't see it love is not necessarily to
marry again I laugh I cry I'm in love
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]